that's right this is an anonymous source  close to the investigation that has been  talking to the newspaper now this hasn't  been corroborated anywhere else it's  just in that newspaper but of course it  is a reputable newspaper and they're  quoting and this anonymous source is  saying that having analyzed the cockpit  voice recorder you can clearly hear the  pilots talking to each other just after  the flight has taken off from Barcelona  and according to this source they were  very smooth very cool conversations  between the two of them but then at some  point in the flight one of the pilots  left to the cockpit and the door was  shut and then this is what the anonymous  source says minutes before the crash  happened the guy outside is knocking  likely on the door and there is no  answer and then he hits the door  stronger and no answer there is never an  answer you can hear he is trying to  smash the door down